>> President Trump: THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
RECENTLY STATED DESPITE THE
MOMENTOUS EFFORTS OF EDUCATORS
DURING THE PANDEMIC, ONLINE
LEARNING HAS NEVER BEEN AN
EFFECTIVE REPLACEMENT FOR
IN-PERSON LEARNING.
WE KNOW SCHOOL CLOSURES HARM
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE MOST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LESS ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY REMOTE LEARNING.
>> Trace: PRESIDENT TRUMP
MAKING THE CASE TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS STRESSING THE
IMPORTANCE OF IN-PERSON
LEARNING AND THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE.
U.S. SECRETARY OF EDUCATION
BETSY DEVOS JOINS US NOW.
SECRETARY DEVOS, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
IT SEEMS TO ME.
I WANT TO PUT THESE GALLUP
POLLS ON THE SCREEN.
IT SEEMS TO ME AND A LOT OF
AMERICANS FOR THE PUSH TO GET
IN-PERSON LEARNING IS LOSING
STEAM.
YOU SEE FROM MAY 25th TO JUNE
8th.
56% OF THE POPULATION WANTED IN
PERSON SCHOOL AND YOU MOVE
FORWARD TO JULY AND NOW DOWN TO
36%.
SO THE WHOLE PUSH SEEMS TO BE
LOSING STEAM.
WHAT DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT IT IS A
COORDINATED EFFORT IN A
CAMPAIGN TO CONTINUE TO SEW
FEAR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT FACTS AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE SCIENCE WE KNOW
THE IMPORTANT THING FOR KIDS IS
TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK INTO
SCHOOL, INTO THEIR CLASSROOMS,
BACK WITH THEIR PEERS, BACK
WITH THEIR TEACHERS AND
LEARNING IN PERSON.
AND FOR MOST STUDENTS THIS IS
THE CASE.
THERE ARE SOME FOR WHOM IT IS
NOT THE RIGHT ANSWER BUT WE
NEED KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL
LEARNING.
AS SECRETARY AZAR HAS
RIGHTFULLY SAID THIS IS A
MATTER OF HEALTH VERSUS HEALTH.
CHILDREN’S MENTAL GROWTH AND
WELL-BEING, THEIR SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL GROWTH.
THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
ALL OF IT RELATES TO A
CONTINUED EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE BACK IN SCHOOL FULL-TIME.
>> Trace: YOU TALK ABOUT
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE AND YOU
MENTIONED SECRETARY AZAR.
BACK IN JUNE THE CDC WAS SAYING
THAT THE RISK TO CHILDREN
APPEARS TO BE VERY LOW.
WE’VE HAD A LITTLE CHANGE SINCE
THEN BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND THE CHILDREN’S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION BETWEEN JULY 9 AND
AUGUST 6 THERE WERE 179 PLUS
THOUSAND CASES OF CHILDREN
GETTING THE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S AN INCREASE OF 90% OVER
FOUR WEEKS.
DOES THAT NUMBER GIVE YOU PAUSE
AT ALL, SECRETARY?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN
ARE GOING TO GET THE VIRUS.
ADULTS ARE GOING TO GET THE
VIRUS.
THE FACTS HAVE BEEN THAT THE
VIRUS HAS NOT IMPACTED CHILDREN
IN THE SAME WAY THAT EVEN THE
AVERAGE FLU SEASON DOES.
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY SUCCUMBED TO THE
VIRUS VERSUS THE FLU IS 1/6 THE
AMOUNT OF AN ANNUAL RATE.
SO AGAIN THE FOCUS REALLY NEEDS
TO BE ON DOING THE RIGHT THINGS.
THE CDC HAS PROVIDED A LOT OF
GUIDANCE AND A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
MANY SCHOOLS HAVE REOPENED AND
THEY ARE DOING SO SUCCESSFULLY
WHEN THEY FOLLOW THIS GUIDANCE
AND THEY TAKE THE MATTER
SERIOUSLY.
BUT THE POINT IS THEY ARE DOING
THE THINGS, SOME OF THEM HARD,
SOME OF THEM UNUSUAL FOR A
NORMAL SCHOOL CIRCUMSTANCE, BUT
THEY ARE DOING THE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE TO GET KIDS
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM AND
BACK INTO THEIR LEARNING.
>> Trace: THE PRESIDENT
FLOATING THIS IDEA SECRETARY
DEVOS OF HAVING THE MONEY
FOLLOW THE CHILDREN AND THE
SCHOOLS THAT OPEN GIVING THEM
SOME MONEY AND THE SCHOOLS THAT
DON’T PULLING BACK SOME MONEY
AND GIVING IT TO THE KIDS.
THE PUSHBACK HAS BEEN PRETTY
SEVERE FROM DEMOCRATS AND
EDUCATORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
>> WE MAKE A PROMISE WHEN WE
INVEST IN EDUCATION AND THAT IS
TO ACTUALLY EDUCATE CHILDREN.
AND THAT PROMISE IS MADE TO
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND IF THAT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN, THE PRESIDENT IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE THE POWER TO TAKE
THOSE RESOURCES AND FIND A
SCHOOL OR AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS GOING TO WORK FOR THEM.
WE’RE SEEING A LOT OF SCHOOLS,
A LOT OF CHARTER SCHOOLS, A LOT
OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
SUCCESSFULLY REOPENING AND WE
NEED TO INSURE THAT PARENTS AND
CHILDREN HAVE THESE OPTIONS AS
WELL.
>> Trace: IT IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU SEE A
LOT OF THESE PATCHWORK PLANS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND LASTLY I
WANT TO PUT THIS UP THERE.
GEORGIA SCHOOLS SEEM TO BE A
LOT OF FOCUS.
A LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT’S HAPPENING THERE.
THEY OPENED, 59 CONFIRMED CASES.
THEY HAVE MORE THAN 1,000
STUDENTS QUARANTINED.
THIS APPEARS TO BE WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE RISK AND YOU
BELIEVE THAT EVERYBODY IS STILL
ON BOARD IN THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH GOING FORWARD SAYING WE’LL
HAVE SETBACK BUT IN THE END
THERE ARE KIDS THAT NEED
STUDENT MEALS, THEY NEED
INTERNET, THEY NEED SUPERVISION
AND THEY NEED TO GET BACK IN
SCHOOL.
>> THEY NEED TO GET BACK IN
AND AGAIN THE CDC HAS PROVIDED
VERY GOOD INFORMATION, VERY
GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS AND
GUIDANCE, AND HAVE LAID OUT
PROCEDURES FOR RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR WHAT TO DO WHEN YOU DO HAVE
A CASE OR A COUPLE OF CASES IN
A SCHOOL.
AND IF THOSE THINGS ARE
FOLLOWED AND THEY ARE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY, A LOT OF THIS CAN BE
ADDRESSED VERY EFFECTIVELY.
WE’RE SEEING IT IN MANY SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SEE IT MORE AS THOSE THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING WHAT’S RIGHT
FOR KIDS ACTUALLY DO PROVIDE
IN-PERSON LEARNING AND PROVIDE
THEM THE OPTION OF BEING THERE
FIVE DAYS A WEEK LEARNING,
MOVING AHEAD AS THEY SHOULD BE
DOING.
KIDS ONLY IS 7 ONE TIME IN
THEIR LIFE.
YOU CAN’T GET THAT TIME BACK.
THAT’S TRUE FOR CHILDREN OF ALL
AGES.